hi I'm Dana Carvey and I'm about to do
the Google autocorrect interview you may
be asking yourself why am I doing this
in the form of torture
Dana Carvey is married ah that's true
been married for 34 years got married in
high school
pretty good marriage but even in the
best marriage even in the best marriage
at one point you look at your spouse and
think not my best choice Dana Carvey is
from Dana Carvey is an Ironman - ah yes
I was the the Mickey Rourke character
with a big lightning bolt slashing thing
that was me
I was not an Iron Man - but I take a
daily iron supplement Dana Carvey is
Hans uh or Franz I am Hans and if you
can know the difference believe me your
buttocks are soft like marshmallows
you're lucky I don't have a campfire
here Dana Carvey
is on Twitter unfortunately I guess I am
my Irish cousin got me on it because I
just want to know what it was and say he
says it's only polite you should follow
anyone who follows you so I'm literally
following I think around 70,000 people
Dana Carvey in State Farm commercial yes
that was Hans and Franz for State Farm
can you say chi-ching it was fun to hang
out with Aaron Rodgers the great
football player you know you could say
stuff to him like your little flabby
girlie man
you better undo your ballad my cuz of La
belong Dana Carvey is Canadian I get
this a lot because of Jim Carrey and
Mike Meyers I'm actually Montanan I was
born about I guess it's probably 100
miles from Canada but I like the
Canadians they are docile and sweet a
big night for a Canadian is to stand on
the border between Canada and America
with a Molson's and go want to see a
felony steps over step back living high
now um how old is Dana Carvey should I
say or make you google it I would say
google it
get off your ration use the freakin web
how sexy is Dana Carvey you know alright
how old was Dana Carvey in Wayne's World
when I was 36 and the second one I was
38 and I was I've never thought I was
playing younger I just thought Garth was
38 but in the second one Mike puts in a
line he says and Garth finally got boobs
you know
so I said to Mike really seriously how
much is Dana Carvey worth that's another
one you got at Google now celebrity net
worth or they accurate I don't know I
don't know I'll leave that to you what'd
you say to say I'm not hunting
how long has Dana Carvey been married a
long time you know my wife is a knockout
I married up for sure that that's it's
amazing that anyone would find this
aging carcass attractive hold your
applause and this is the final look how
much to book Dana Carvey basically
here's a way here's a way to express it
Microsoft asked me to do the church lady
with Bill Gates at one of their big
conventions and I said no I don't sell
out the church lady and then they told
me how much they were gonna pay me I
said I'll get the bitch's dress on right
now is SNL funny yes the last thing in
life you want to be is one of these
grumpy old men and show business is like
it was always better before it's an
impossible show to do cut them some
slack but my friend Lauren Michaels once
said you know all the show doesn't go on
because it's ready to go on because it's
like 11:30 is SNL film live no it's
taped in a two-week period right around
Christmas yes it is filmed live and if
you don't know that it's live you need
help is SNL funny anymore
can we get that one somewhere yes it is
it's very very funny it hasn't finished
well you can see how these questions
kind of interweave a little bit yes it's
funny and it's not finished mmm
where did Dana Carvey grow up I was I
was born in Missoula lived there till I
was about five and then I grew up in San
Carlos which
is on the peninsula south of San
Francisco where did Dana Carvey go
I took 15 years off to raise my sons
because you know I didn't want to be an
absentee dad true story there is a New
York actor who was doing so many movies
and his kid was raised by a British
nanny that when he would call home would
be like hey this is Johnny Stompanato
who's Johnny Stompanato jr. there hello
daddy it's your son Johnny stepping up
Junior so I wanted to avoid that where
is Dana Carvey performing everywhere I
just signed a secret contract to play in
Las Vegas where is Dana Carvey now in a
chair on the 97th floor two skyscraper
in LA sighs make much yeah nice chamois
and I know it's great I like being in
you know a place with them you know
tendency for seismic activity you know
where did Dana Carvey go to high school
uh I went to Carmel High School in San
Carlos California and I was just a shy
introverted kid I never took theater hi
my name is Dana Carvey and that was my
autocomplete interview and now tell your
husband or wife that you love them